Boys, some of y'all are out here looking straight goofy when y'all
submit these fraudulent PPP loans and you're not sophisticated.
You're total amateurs. You're gonna go to jail.
For being such an idiot.
So today we're going to look at some of the dumbest things I've seen welcome to
the PPB Chronicle.
Something like the liar, but the size of that, the puppies,
and they went the cut. Oh, they went, it would be God.
And if you have a small sloppy puppy, that is okay,
but you must not lie to the government.
Not the government may be a new girlfriend.
Welcome new. The beep beep beep beep beep Chronicle.
Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to the FBI building where I'm going to just recount to you the fact that
the FBI has now gotten involved with some of these PPP fraud cases.
They have something called the complex financial crime squad or something like
that. It sounds much cooler than it probably is. Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to my presentation screen. We here at the FBI, you know,
$10 million studio. Now,
today we're looking at Joshua Bellamy's criminal complaint.
Joshua Bellamy is the former NFL player. He was a wide receiver for the jets.
So, um,
brilliant man in the art of complex financial crimes and how
he got caught. He had something called drip entertainment, LLC.
And he was one of many people. Nine people were charged,
submitting false documents and trying to get money for it from the COVID relief
fund. And this guy got 1 million, $200,000.
Now he got this at a time when he was broke. Apparently when he got it,
the $1.2 million at the time in his personal account,
he had a personal balance of $2 and 51 cents. Now I know what you're thinking.
Poor guy. Maybe he needed the money. Well,
he spent that $1.2 million in two months. Yeah.
That's who we're dealing with. And was it on food? Was it on shelter? No.
He spent it on custom jewelry, uh,
$57,000 in custom jewelry, $38,000 on another jewelry store,
$5,000 at Gucci, a thousand dollars. You guys get the point.
He's trying to get the drip, drip. And, uh,
he got caught and I don't feel bad for him about it. I mean,
the level of this scam was so low.
There's such amateurs at this little organization. Look at this.
The purported company bank statement,
which was submitted in electronic for a format is a clear forgery. First,
according to the documents file properties,
the statement was created using PDF filler program used
to edit electronic PDF files.
I bet that FBI people and all the people who investigated this were like,
are you joking? You're trying to get one bias with PDF.
Feller is probably like the free version or something like that and was modified
using ITEX. Second,
the statement is a recycled version of the same falsified bank.
Seven statement used in other fraudulent applications submitted as part of the
scheme. Oh my gosh.
They're not even bothering redo documents that are submitting the same stuff.
But as if that's enough, they then went and entrapped. This guy,
do the FBI's crushing it up. Tell him this criminal complaint is just scathing.
Apparently an undercover agent posed as an associate and spoke with the guy
basically saying, Hey, I can get you a second PPB loan.
I think this guy is jets wide receiver who just got
$1.2 million from the government. Fraudulently would say, Hey man.
No, my way.
I can't do that.
I'm not going to lie to the government in order to get more money.
I've already stolen money from the government. But instead he goes, yeah,
of course let's do it right. How stupid can you be?
Let me hear, answer that question with his co-conspirator.
His co-conspirator is a little smarter.
It's a guy named Phillip Augustine who was investigated by the FBI.
Now this Augustine guy tried to claim since he was just the hype man for this
business. And he tried to claim that, look, it wasn't his doing,
he was a victim. It says that it was CHS too. Who's just this other guy.
Who's unnamed who submitted the application from Augustine's house using
Augustine's computer. Your honor, I did. I,
it may have come from my computer. The fraud may have been found on my computer,
but I did not touch my computer. In fact,
he later they're told, uh, prosecutors that he was,
he was only providing documents while he was playing two games of pool and
didn't know that any fraud was happening. Now,
the problem with that was that they went and they checked his phone records.
Like these people think that the government's incompetent,
which in a lot of ways it is,
but they think that there's no such thing as telephone records.
And basically the telephone records paint a different picture because this
alleged victim and the guy preparing the documents were texting back and forth
the whole time. And why would you text back and forth from the same room?
If one of you guys are playing pool. So it doesn't make sense.
Not only that his signatures matched the same signatures from his bank records
from all his private records. And so they're like, yeah,
you definitely did this crime.
But now because this guy lied to prosecutors because he tried to cover up his
crime and tried to say, no, I was the victim. Look at this. In that interview,
he falsely portrayed himself to be the victim.
He might be getting prosecuted under obstruction of the investigation,
which to me I'm loving it.
I'm all here for watching these scammers get exposed. You know,
I love this stuff. Look, you lie to the government. You lie to the Americans.
You say you have these businesses that are saving jobs,
you get paid and then you go blow it all. Like have you noticed? Yes,
it's a common theme with the PPB Chronicles that all these people,
they don't just get the loan money and then go help the poor, right?
They don't get the loan money and go feed puppies at the, at the shelter.
They get the loan money and spend it on custom jewelry.
But these people have no shame.
They don't even think they're going to get caught.
They're too arrogant to think that they're going to caught. And when they.
Do, Oh, I love it.
And just know if you're out there scamming, they're gonna catch you.
These people are not dumped while reading these case files. I was like.
Boy. I didn't.
Know. They could do that. They're checking the text logs, the phone logs.
They're checking that dude.
They're checking how many squares you use on the toilet? Trust me,
these people know you better than you know yourself by the time they've
investigated you. So don't think you're going to get away with it.
You may get away with it for a little bit. You may be arrogant.
You may be in your new bins that you just bought thinking, Oh man,
I got away with it. Let me apply for another COVID loan. No dude,
you just got away with it for now. You're going to get caught.
And when they bust you,
you will be appearing in the PPB Chronicles and we will be celebrating your
downfall because you're stealing money anyways. That's it guys.
Let me know what you think of the comments below. And as always.
Don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.
[inaudible].